or have a new trailer to hellboy the
second trailer it's a red band trailer
so bring the kids when the first trailer
dropped I was like I'm gonna process
that I don't know what to think about it
but this one's alright I was entertained
because I personally I like the whole
heaven versus hell and people vs. hell
in people vs. heaven and basically the
physical plane versus the ethereal I
like the Keanu Reeves Constantine that's
what I'm trying to say sue me so this is
at least as entertaining as that I'll be
fine it being a reboot of Hellboy
re-envisioning that the origins similar
but different like on this island off
the coast of Scotland that's where the
Nazis summoned Hellboy just one dudes
even gonna watch it in 3d
what's was it nasty with the 3d glasses
rebranding must have been it's no longer
the Third Reich it's the 3d right
it's like Biff's friend became an aza I
can go on and on point is we have David
Harbor as hell blurring there's even a
lot of people in comments section was
like nope Ron Perlman's Hellboy that's
it which is the part of me that's like
well I mean Hellboy is actually a comic
book he can be played by other actors
but I totally get it Ron Perlman brought
something to Hell boy he made Hellboy
human I mean I'm a big Metal Gear Solid
fan huge Hideo Kojima fan never played
Metal Gear Rising why cuz he didn't
direct it so I was like no respect you
got to draw the line somewhere I've been
informed I'm missing out still not gonna
play it so I get it who am I to judge I
guess that's a huge hurdle that the
entertainment industry as a whole has to
continually try to get over and that's
the nature of sentimentality
David Harbour does look like he's good
as hell boy he looks a bit less lovable
like whether or not I don't know maybe
it's just me Ron Perlman Hellboy he
looked kind of lovable but badass this
dude looks like ya maybe you were under
my bed when I was a child he looks like
a monster which that's what they're
going for he's a demon from hell he's
not supposed to be now he's not supposed
to look nice anyway and you totally feel
that tone in this trailer this isn't the
2004 to 2008 fun stylistic pg-13 action
piece the original Hellboy was and
Hellboy 2 the Golden Army this looks
like they kind of want to make it look
like a horror movie they want to make it
hyper violent they want some things to
look scary sometimes it looks like an
80s death metal rock album cover I just
hope that they focus it up I hope they
don't try to do so many things and make
it feel like so many things it doesn't
really feel like anything if it's a cool
action movie with horror elements up
totally down one could argue that was
the original Hellboy well this time it's
rated up there's gonna be a lot more
cursing in blood and Milla Jovovich
isn't it that's helped
she looks great I hope I ate so well I
don't know who she is like in terms of
history or methis or Laura mean Rasputin
that's
but you know there's a stories about
Rasputin she looks like the red woman
from Game of Thrones just kind of had it
with Westeros came here to start some
[ __ ] what's her name milah sandra it's
something like that well I suppose if
I'm wrong comments-section will let me
know I will say the creature designs
that they do have a Guillermo del Toro
quality to them don't that you know they
were like alright we're gonna pull some
inspiration or maybe they pulled
inspiration from the graphic novel I
only read the first trade don't
recognize really anything from here
that's in the first trade which is
that's pretty boss right there I was
actually surprised they showed him with
the crown and the horns which was the
big thing at the end of Hellboy I was
like the big reveal it's like you're the
weapon you're the big bad guy but you
have a choice and that's the whole
lesson there whose trailers like alright
everyone knows that people just want to
see this movie they saw the original
Hellboy so just show them show them
putting the nazgûl to shame like that's
pretty sweet-looking and this the last
line in the trailer it's solidified it I
was like yeah I want to see it because
we need Hellboy to talk some mad [ __ ]
and that last line was some mad [ __ ] not
even gonna replicate it because it's too
good for me to replicate here it's just
this you know I'm a Capricorn and you're
beautiful that's love so yeah I thought
the new Hellboy trailer was sweet I'm
interested to see what David Harbor
brings to the character how boy like I
said before I hope they focus it up and
make it all blend alright so there's a
trailer to Hellboy have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]